[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i'm mark stein
tucker is out for a court-ordered
recount of his turkey giblets i hope you
had a wonderful thanksgiving one thing
americans should not be thankful for
however is
the various election systems that
afflict the nation
uh about which regardless of whoever you
think won the presidency too much
is now known if georgia runs
the january senate runoff the same way
it ran this month's general election in
defiance of its own rules and with
obvious
cod swallow like a supposed burst water
pipe
shutting down the count if they do it
that way next time then the democrats
will win
both seats take control of the senate
and if that happens
unlike the mythical pipe bursts of
fulton county
apue sala deluge a transformative deluge
from a senate that will sweep away
institutional obstacles and stack
the odds against any meaningful
alternative to the democrat party for
years
to come direct from his thanksgiving
dinner with a maximum of nine persons
from no more than two households
here's chuck schumer now we take georgia
and then we change the world yeah
i'm sorry
now we take georgia and then we change
america
when a guy spells out what he's going to
do to you don't act surprised when he
does it to you good and hard
president trump has now joined the fight
in georgia
he and these two senators were both on
the receiving end to one degree or
another
of an election racket whose flaws the
state has already admitted to
just eight weeks ago this rather curious
supposedly republican secretary of state
announced that at least 1 000 people had
voted
twice in the primary and that this was a
serious
intentional fraud upon the people of
georgia quote
those that make the choice to game the
system are breaking the law
and as secretary of state i will not
tolerate
oh he sounded so butch way back when in
september
but he seems to be a lot more tolerant
of it just
two months later so the president will
be holding rallies
in georgia to help these senators over
the finish line
regardless of how many double voters
turn up or whatever
torrent of burst sewer lines
closes down the counting centers from
atlanta to the sea
this is the new georgia we're told it's
no longer a reliable red state it's all
purple now it's all swing statey now
where a moderate democrat can run to the
center and
unseat a republican so how centrist how
moderate
is kelly luffler's democrat opponent uh
he's this moderate he's anti-gun he's
anti-cop he's anti-trump
and more than that he's anti-all you
enablers
of trump and if it is true that
a man who has dominated the news and
poisoned the discussion for months needs
to repent
then it is doubly true that a nation
that can produce such a man and make his
vitriol go viral
needs to repent no matter what happens
next month more than a third of the
nation that would go along with this
is reason to be afraid america needs to
repent
for its worship of whiteness
does that sound like a viable swing
state moderate to you the susan collins
of georgia
or does that sound like a crazy radical
the georgia democrats are going to need
the shenanigan express going full
throttle down the track
to drag to victory